Last week, we discussed
the kinematics of motion.
How one describes the
motion of an object
by specifying its position,
velocity, and acceleration
as a function of time.
This week, we will
continue by discussing
the dynamics of motion.
How the application
of forces on an object
changes the geometry or
trajectory of its motion.
We will see that the applied
forces and the change
in trajectory are related
through Newton's laws
of motion.
We will begin by reviewing
Newton's three laws of motion.
These were a
landmark achievement
in scientific thought.
Most people who
haven't studied physics
tend to intuitively think in
terms of the ancient mechanics
of Aristotle in which an applied
force is required to maintain
a body in uniform motion.
Superficially,
this seems to agree
with our everyday
experience, but only
because friction plays
such an important role
in our everyday life.
One of Newton's
great insights was
that applied forces cause
changes in an object's motion,
rather than being necessary
to maintain uniform motion.
Newton's laws were
the end result
of a great deal of
careful definition,
observation, and reasoning
by many scientists
up to and including Newton.
It is a fascinating
and compelling chapter
in the history of science,
but we will not discuss
that history in this course.
Instead, we will simply state
Newton's three laws of motion
as assumed postulates or axioms
and discuss their meaning
and application.
Finally, we will consider
several specific examples
of physical forces, such as
gravity, contact forces exerted
by a solid surface, like the
so-called normal force, which
acts perpendicular or
normal to the surface,
and friction, which acts
parallel to the surface,
pulling forces like
tension in a rope or chain,
and the force exerted by a
stretched or compressed spring
described by Hooke's law.
Taken as a whole,
this week will show us
how to connect the two sides of
Newton's Second Law of Motion,
f equals ma, the
dynamics or application
of forces on the left-hand
side and its relation
to the kinematics, the change in
geometry of the object's motion
or trajectory, on
the right-hand side.